it's 4am you've been awake for 40 hours
when you unlock a puzzle containing this
video
of some kind of dance-off between a
chicken and a roller skating beaver
the confusion and delight you're
experiencing is a typical moment at the
mit mystery hunt which is basically the
olympics meets burning man for a
specific type of nerd
today i'm going to take you inside this
strange
intellectually masochistic and
incredibly joyful world but first i have
to explain when i what i mean when i say
puzzle
a puzzle hunt style puzzle
is a data set it can be a grid of
letters a sudoku
a video an audio it can be anything that
contains hidden information that can
eventually resolve into an answer that
is a word or a phrase so to give you an
example this is a puzzle called
masterpieces it consists of 10 images of
lego people looking at piles of legos
and to save us some time i'm going to
explain what's going on here
each of the piles of legos is a
deconstructed work of art in the style
of a famous artist so does anybody
recognize the one the artist on the left
they used a lot of red
i heard rothko yeah
the second one uh
yeah
well done
and the third one
this is the hardest one uh
yeah clamped i heard it well done the
color and is the biggest clue there
so
the puzzle has various clues that tell
you what matters here are the artists
not the specific works of art and what
you need to do is then look at what you
haven't used yet which is the number of
lego people in each painting
and you can count them and then count
into the artist's last names by the same
number of letters so there's three
people in front of the rothko on the
left so you take the third letter which
is a t
there's only one in front of the
mondrian so you take the first letter m
and there's three again in front of
klimt so you take the third letter i
you do that for all 10 of the original
artists and put them in the order and
you get the answer which is illuminate
puzzles like this are about
communicating an idea
but where i'm trying to be as clear as
possible for you now puzzles have to
navigate the line between abstraction
and clarity
they have to be obtuse enough
to make you work for it
but elegant enough so that you can get
to the aha moment where everything
clicks into place puzzle solvers are
junkies for this aha moment it feels
like a brief high and an instant of
pristine clarity
and
there's also a deeper fulfillment at
play here which is that
humans are innate problem solvers it's
why we love crosswords and escape rooms
and figuring out how to explore the
bottom of the ocean
solving deviously difficult puzzles
expands our minds in new directions
and it also helps us
come at problems from diverse
perspectives
these puzzles come in various puzzle
hunts which come in various shapes and
sizes there's one hour ones designed for
novices 24-hour road rallies and the
puzzle hunt of puzzle hunts the mit
mystery hunt
this is an event that takes place once a
year and has thousands of around 2000
people descending on mit's campus
and solving puzzles and teams that range
from a single person to over a hundred
my team has 60 people on it that
includes a national crossword puzzle
tournament champion
a particle physicist a composer an
actual deep sea explorer
and me feeling like mr bean goes to
bletchley park
that's actually an apt comparison
because one year involved a puzzle where
you had to construct a working enigma
machine out of pieces of cardboard
each mystery hunt has a theme past ones
have included the matrix and alice in
wonderland it's often pop culture and
literary uh based themes and the goal is
to find the coin that's been hidden
somewhere on mit's campus and in order
to get there you have to solve around
150 puzzles and do various events and
challenges
i had done this for about 10 years
without ever dreaming of winning until
january of 2016 we're 53 hours into a
hunt whose theme is the movie inception
we haven't slept in days and so
everything is hilarious
the tables are covered in piles of
papers of our notes and completed
puzzles the whiteboards are an
unintelligible mess of three days worth
of insights
and we're stuck on two puzzles if we
could crack them we would get into the
end game and after hours of work in a
magical moment they both fall within 10
seconds of each other and soon we're on
the final run around a series of clues
that will lead us to the coin
and we're racing through the halls of
mit trying not to knock over or terrify
tour groups
when we realize we're not alone there's
another team on the run around as well
and we don't know who's ahead
so we're a mess of anxiety anticipation
exhilaration and sleep deprivation when
we arrive at the alchemist
a sculpture in which we find
this coin
yeah
and in claiming it we win the mit
mystery hunt by a tiny margin of five
minutes
what i didn't mention before is that the
prize for winning is that you get to
construct the whole hunt for the
following year
the punishment for winning is that you
have to construct the whole hunt for the
following year
at the beginning of 2016 i had never
constructed a puzzle before i had solved
plenty of puzzles but constructing and
solving are entirely different beasts
but once again i was lucky to be on a
team full of brilliant mentors and
collaborators
so from a constructor's point of view a
puzzle is where i have an idea and
instead of telling you what it is i'm
going to leave a trail of breadcrumbs so
you can figure it out for yourself and
have the joy and experience of the aha
moment this is another way of looking at
the aha moment
and what's incredible to me is that this
experience which is very emotional and
kind of almost physical is something
that can be carefully designed
so to show you what i mean this is a
puzzle i co-constructed with my friend
matt gruskin it's a text adventure which
is the old school adventure game format
where you're exploring going north east
south and west picking up items and
using them
and you could get to the end of the game
part but you won't have solved the
puzzle in order to do so you have to
recognize a hidden layer of information
and the easiest way of seeing it is by
mapping the game out that looks
something like this
does anybody recognize what this is
yeah exactly this is uh this text
adventure takes place within settlers of
catan
who here knows what settlers
nerds
if you don't know settlers is a board
game where you're competing against
other people to collect resources and
use them to build structures
and within the game within the text
adventure we hid information in various
ways with which you could reconstruct an
entire game you could figure out the
roads the cities the towns the resources
the numbers on the tiles even the dice
rolls you put all that information
together and you could extract an answer
in a way that's too complicated to
explain right now
but find me afterwards if you really
want to know
but what this puzzle emphasized for me
is the value of perspective shifts in
inspiring and aha so in this puzzle you
go from experiencing the world on the
ground as a character to looking down on
it from above as if you're playing a
board game and in that shift you
completely reframe all the information
you've been given
the hardest part of construction for me
is coming up with a great idea for an
aha
fortunately the world is a torrent of
ideas and information i've seen
fantastic puzzles constructed out of the
waggle dances of bees and the remarkable
coincidence that the 88 keys of a piano
can be perfectly mapped to the 88
constellations in the sky once you find
that out you can't not construct the
puzzle and it's going to be about having
the solvers make that connection in
their own minds whether you give them
stars on a keyboard or play the
celestial music of the cosmos you're
getting them there one way or another
before long you find yourself staring at
a turtle and asking yourself is this a
puzzle
and also staring at a turtle and saying
i never appreciated what multitudes this
contains in its shell alone
this might be a familiar experience to
you if you've ever been watching a ted
talk and asked yourself is this a puzzle
i'm not telling
but what i will say is that puzzles can
be found in the most unexpected of
places
that brings us back to one of my
favorite puzzles of all time which was
constructed by tripp payne and this time
i'm going to play it for you with the
sound on so get ready to name that tune
[Music]
who knows what that is
yeah you make me feel like a natural
woman
[Laughter]
so you can identify that in seven of
other songs and clips and then look at
the videos themselves for clues where
the way that they are filmed and edited
together plus cut things like the
cutaways to the panel of five people
sitting at a table which is reminiscent
of a panel of judges all of this can
suggest reality competition show
and either through internet research or
from just recognizing this you can get
to the aha which is that these clips are
shot for shot recreations of lip sync
battles from rupaul's drag race
[Laughter]
so why do we do this
you tell me i don't know so first of all
it's really fun
but i think it also improves our lives
in various ways uh being able to solve
puzzles has when i'm confronted with a
challenge has allowed me to explore it
from multiple perspectives before i lock
in and approach
it's also the process of solving is
great training for working with a team
knowing when to listen when to share and
how to recognize and celebrate insight
and be being able to construct ahaz is a
very powerful tool think of how powerful
and exciting and convincing an idea is
that comes from your own mind
where you make all the connections
yourself
so in january of 2017
after about ten
tens of thousands of hours of work we
finally run our mystery hunt and it's a
different sort of satisfaction than the
quick high of an aha moment instead it's
the slow burn of saying something
through perplexing abstraction
yet being understood
and when it was all over in our
exhaustion we turned to each other and
the world and we said we're never doing
this again it's too much work
it's really fun but no more winning
one year later in january of 2018
we won the mit mystery hunt again
[Laughter]
so we're currently i don't know how many
tens of thousands of hours of work in
and we're two months out from the 2019
hunt so thank you for listening i have
to go write a puzzle
[Applause]